all right let's start to look at this
together because by now you put down
your lines you've got some angles
measured there as well and I'm now just
saying to write some stuff out for what
you have observed so everyone's lines
are going to look slightly different
which is lovely but they'll probably
look vaguely like this and we're gonna
point out a few things so first question
we asked you to draw a couple of
parallel lines does anyone know what's
the way I show on the diagram the two
lines are parallel what do i indicate
vishakha very good so the lines that are
parallel in on mine like they sort of
look vaguely parallel right I'm going to
indicate them with a couple of hours
ahead in the same direction if I had
lots of parallel lines like different
pairs then I might have you know two
arrows on each one so long as they're
matching up together okay
I could even have like a third line over
here that was also parallel if I wanted
to show that I just put another arrow
thumbs up so if you haven't done that on
yours please go ahead and put those on
now after that hopefully you've measured
all of your angles I've got eight
probably you've got eight as well you
may or may not have used color but I use
color to indicate some things that are
equal and some things that are not we'll
talk about them in a second but lastly
when you're starting to write your
reasoning you might have noticed it's
hard to talk about these angles and
explain them to someone else without
kind of holding out your diagram and
like pointing to a thing because nothing
is labeled at the moment nothing has a
name right I would like to be able to
talk about these different angles and
not be able to say will not be forced to
say hey you know that one sort of in the
middle of the diagram no the other
middle like facing that direction that's
all really long and ambiguous so I'm
gonna put some names on this and I'd
like you to do the same you know you're
parallel lines
I'd like you to name them like this cool
one of them a and on the other end B and
we really can't name these anything but
just to be consistent then we'll have
some good language here I'm gonna call
the other one because it's parallel C D
and then right down the middle here I've
got this special line now you can see
this is that third line that cuts across
and I sort of highlighted cuts across
does anyone know this
special words that's for the tea that
means a word that cuts across both are
the lines they handed you know
transversal if you've never heard that
word before
and let me write it down for all of us
trans live transport transversal it's
the word it's a it's just means it cuts
across all the other ones this
transversal we want to have sort of I'm
gonna have some different letters going
across here and there's one two three
four places so I'm going to call these
guys I need another color here I'm gonna
call this P Q R s so I've got ABCD that
gives me my parallel lines and then this
guy cutting across PQRS all right now we
can start to talk about some of things
you observe I'd love to get some
volunteers to maybe share one thing at a
time and then as you share it I'd love
us it has a class to try and work out
where on this diagram we have ways to
describe everything can we see the thing
that's in pointed out by someone so okay
Christian O'Grady second Louise you
start off what do you say okay so so
hopefully the first thing that all of us
is there's loads of numbers that are
identical they're equal to each other
right I think crucial if you tell me
about a specific thing that's related to
that okay so we've got some language
here that we need to immediately America
come to you right next let's let's talk
about Christians point at first there
are Co interior angles on this now if
you've never met that phrase before you
can't remember from last yeah Chris John
can you tell me what can anyone else
help me out and name for me a couple of
angles that are Co interior Haider can
you give me an example okay so you said
100 point nine and 31 which are the
sizes of those angles right however on
my diagram I have a whole lot of 149 and
a whole lot of thirty ones can someone
name is specific 149 for me and a
specific 31 here
okay pause right there a Q R so you can
see the way that hearing name this in
fact I'd love you all to follow along
with me angle a cube ah okay yep so that
one is this blue 149° okay
which one can someone pick up from him
which angle is co interior to a Q R
what's the name of it hmm David what're
you thinking P Q a so here's PQ a over
here
okay now this relay this angle is
related to our a QR but I'm Co interior
like that would it gives us no clue as
to what it means what does interior mean
and someone's an interior designer what
is it that they design things that are
inside right like a like a ruler so like
that
so is this interior like inside with 149
unfortunately not it's got a different
relationship will come to that but Lea
what do you see this Co interior CE o qu
agree with that
q okay fantastic so I can write angle a
QR and angle what do we just say c RQ c
q r co interior and that literally means
together inside right and because their
Co interior what do you notice about the
numbers 149 31 what do you see ya gradua
okay so when were young when we add them
up together 149 plus 31 we get 180 do
you remember we encountered a word
yesterday and last year that means you
add them together 180 can someone else
help Krishan out someone different yeah
ocean supplementary very good AQ r and c
RQ r co interior and supplementary in
fact there's another pair of co interior
angles on here and they are also
supplementary can someone tell me what's
the other pair okay can you give me a
lot of good suggestions I want like if
someone else can pick up from there say
here new can you give me another pair
say that again sandwich the balada okay
so when we said our here
ours are really helpful in the important
point but unfortunately I've got like a
lot of angles that are I've got one two
three four right so which angle did you
mean which one were you afraid to is
handy see our s this one over here s s
which other one yes RC wait that's the
same one isn't it
no it s RC and CRS Oh My those guys are
really close together they're like the
same angle okay this guy here on my
diagram anyway actually is not Co
interior to anything I don't have
another guy on this side and red you
only helped me out what's the other pair
of Co interior angles or were you going
to tell me something else okay there
they're all angles at a point it's very
good Harry do you want to give us the
last pair of code Rose drq that's this
guy and B Q R this guy great what makes
them Cohen terior you see they're
together inside this kind of little box
here does that make sense right once you
crossed over line you I'm outside not
coming to you anymore okay